how rich is crypto making people is it
rich enough to quit your job check out
this story right here
how many people do you think have quit
their job because of crypto wealth in
the last two years how many people take
a guess take a guess they can get their
job quit their job on making money on
crypto yes i'll give you a percentage
two percent of what you can't give a
percentage of americans i'm assuming
americans
yeah like a percent give a number i
don't know [ __ ] 100 people no 100 000
people 100 how about your 100 i see
you're 100 000 and i raise you six
million people okay six million people
do six million divided by 330 million
six how many current population in the
united states 330 or 360 million
okay 330 million
divided by what
six million
six million coming up
55.
no it's not no man
no it's not jesus you have the number
one i don't know 6 million divided by
the population 330 million so six
million people
in the u.s workforce have quit their
jobs after making more money from crypto
than their low-income jobs this is a
survey by intelligence firm civic
science you get a number for me
point zero one eight so six million
divided by 320
billion million jesus david so it's it's
one percent it's one percent okay it's
almost two percent almost two percent
boom so i hit it right the first here
are the stats on this you know sorry for
the numbers guys over here six million
people have quit their jobs quote
unquote low paying jobs is what they're
calling it i don't know 50 grand is a
low-paying job
but basically
after acquiring all this crypto wealth
here are some stats for you 11
obviously this is a survey 11 of the
sixty seven hundred respondents people
who are surveyed admitted to having to
quit their jobs
or knowing someone who quit their jobs
after gaining quote-unquote financial
freedom from crypto we'll see what
financial freedom is 64 who quit their
job say they were earning below
50 000 can i get a link here yes sir 53
said they knew somebody who quit for the
same reason so basically people know
people that are quitting 54 that crypto
has made them wealthier in the past five
years no [ __ ]
and then get this you always hear that
millennials are going to be the first
generation that is not going to be as
wealthy as their parents you've heard
this before every generation in u.s
history the kids have been ended up
wealthier than their parents yes that's
the beauty of capitalism in the united
states of america
but you hear that millennials are not
going to be that generation because of
student debt the economy the housing all
that get this number 58 of millennials
and gen z
say they believe they believe they will
be wealthier than their parents
because of crypto crypto is changing
the world yeah crypto is here and it
ain't going
anywhere every day it's more commenting
on the survey
shark tank a friend of the show mark
cuban says wow
four percent is the number four percent
of people in the usa have quit their
jobs because of crypto gains and the
vast majority made under the 50 000
benchmark now we now well now we know
why so many people quit low paying jobs
and this was before
the latest run up right here
so this is pretty damn wild right now if
you're
24 years old
you're making 48 grand a year you're
pulling in four thousand dollars a month
or even less
make it 30 grand a year startup job you
got this crypto wealth
you got unemployment
because you quit your job or you got
laid off because of right because of
kovid and then they're giving you stemi
checks
why the hell would i go back to work
that explains
so
much
okay
i was making 30 grand a year
working at amazon i invested in dogecoin
and bitcoin three years ago i was making
30 grand a year
now i'm sitting at home i'm getting
unemployment checks you've given me
stimulus checks and the 5 000 i invested
in bitcoin is now 50 000
and you want me to go back and work for
your [ __ ] 15 an hour right
not happening
so
it's understandable we hear about the
inflation we hear about the unemployment
we hear about the macroeconomics of
what's going on in america a lot of it
is because these young people are saying
i ain't going back to your shitty ass
job
here's the flip side though
how long
can that last
so if you're used to making 40 grand a
year now you're 50 000 richer how long
is that crypto wealth gonna last a year
exactly two years right and we all know
that even if 50 grand is in your account
100 grand is in your account
you ain't paying rent with that
because you can only acquire the money
when you
sell right so if you sold and now you're
cash strong you don't have any much
crypto
now you're using all that money maybe
you're investing and reinvesting i don't
know so the question is how long can you
live off this crypto
not that long unless you've made
hundreds of thousands of dollars or
millions of dollars so
you better have a um
[Music]
a plan yeah as they say to get back into
the workforce and that we talked about
on the pd podcast when you said your
last job was in 2019 and now it's 2022
what the have you been doing for three
years right what are you gonna put on
your resume
don't undermine the importance of work
work is
like you can't just sit around all day
doing nothing unemployed smoking weed
looking at your crypto gains at some
point you're gonna have to find a
profession
at some point you're gonna have to be an
expert in anything unless you're one of
these crypto guys that made literally a
billion dollars off crypto you're gonna
have to work again i don't think these
people are
stupid and don't understand that maybe
they're just not thinking long term
they're thinking for right now
i'm just gonna sit back collect my
checks
watch my ethereum games or gains or
dogecoin or shibuynu
or bitcoin and just kind of chill for a
while and you know what i don't blame
them
but you better have a long-term
perspective
thoughts marcelo
i agree i think um
everybody's trying to not work
is what it seems to be people are like
crypto's gonna be my ticket baby bitcoin
now i don't have to work anymore it's
like no matter what happens you're
probably gonna have to work again so i
think the people that are really winning
the people that are really really
winning in crypto are the ones that
invested in crypto whatever they were
willing to lose 10 15 whatever if
they're crazy 20 30 they took a big risk
crypto went to the moon and they kept
working their job and they kept grinding
and kept grinding and got better at
their job while their money was working
for them while they were sleeping at
night those are the people that are
really winning the people that went into
crypto and was like this is my ticket
out
it's like some of them are going to make
it right they're going to be crypto
traders for the rest of your life and
then that's just going to be their thing
like day traders for stocks
it's a scary life to live huh
when it's this easy
you got to ask yourself
something's up
right when it's this easy i have a
business partner he's 50 years old his
son is 20. he says my son and all his
friends are just trading crypto
they've got
stupid money for a college kid right
they've got 20 grand 30 grand 50 grand
for a college kid
dude i think i had 400 to my name when i
was in college
so yes these crypto gains are awesome
congratulations a lot of gen z younger
guys that's awesome
but that ain't gonna provide you for the
rest of your life you better have some
work ethic right you better have some
give a [ __ ] level about what you do yeah
i think it's important i i don't even
think people don't want to work you know
i don't actually believe that i think
what people don't want and we cover this
i think maybe episode three of the sauce
cast most americans
just don't want to go back to the office
they don't want to go back to the
[ __ ] restaurant they want to just
work from home yeah so it's like yeah
we'll pay you 15 bucks an hour and you
made your you know your thousands off of
bitcoin
i think i'll work for i mean i think
most people would say yeah i'll work 15
17 bucks an hour you let me work from
home
yeah i'll work i don't give a [ __ ]
hybrid life yeah you get that freedom i
think that's what it is i think most
people are down to work they just want
to work from home and i think episode 3
was like 60 of americans would work from
home like we continue working for them
forever david locked in dialed in either
way
we all agree you got to be working
whether you're making money on crypto or
not at some point you get it back in the
workplace is money
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken